le président chirac il songeait depuis
longtemps et aura finalement réussi à
convaincre son ami serge dassault les
deux constructeurs aéronautiques
dassault aviation et aérospatiale pour
plus ample au mur face à la rude
concurrence et du pain entrée avec 60
milliards de francs de chiffre
d'affaires cumulé les lieux groupe soucy
plural 4
s'alarme aérospatiale est surtout connu
pour ses collages et produits que
domicile
l'association pas pu tenir à geler mm ou
des balkans par cet accord la
baptisation la seconde s'est échappé de
partout en estrie en échange serge
dassault est vrai pour les 27% et
présidait le conseil de surveillance
mais l'accord ne sera vraiment finaliser
et c'est là que le dossier du souci car
le montant n'est pas encore rétablie et
les droits de succession compliquer le
sevrage
il racontera
quel culot